have you ever watched an episode of The
Bachelor yeah I know how it works like
they you know they all have their own
introductions like I think I know you're
gonna say the accent girl no no no
nothing to do with that that was funny
know what I was gonna get out was so it
seems like they have you know if there's
a formula like one girl shows up in a
costume one girl shows up in a crazy car
away and well it's funny to me is this
one girl shows up in a costume spoiler
alert it's a sloth okay and it's like a
play on the dude because he's a virgin
and that's the big drama is that he's a
virgin and he's been getting a lot of
[ __ ] thrown in his face for being a
virgin whatever we'll get into that in a
second oh yeah so she gets out the car
in us in a sloth costume like playing on
him moving slow
so she commits to this what is probably
like real time probably like a 10-15
minute act out of her just going hey it
yeah yeah you can feel that oh you
cringy you can feel that cringey I know
watching it and you feel how bad it is
oh yeah yeah he's staring and he tries
to make a joke back to her going this is
gonna take a really long time and she
stays with it she commits the whole way
that's the only way to do that though
hmm
you can't give up halfway cuz that's
even more cringe yep once you're in it
yeah you just got to do it and she does
it all the way until like she hugs him
and then she rolls out so then at some
point she she can smote it off yeah he's
like first did you get yet she gets like
10 feet away from he turns to the
bruiser she's out yes he doesn't even
you just sent her back to the road money
now just she's done that was weirdest
[ __ ] I don't know what why was that eat
why did you guys let her do that that
was so weird
she's off it just goes a little Zayn huh
why the [ __ ] would you do that she's
like oh oh oh it's cuz like you know why
the [ __ ] would you do that let me I mean
it was just posed to be like a light
sort of which is a joke about like get
out nice to meet you
so bro she crawls up in his tree and
every they had so many sound bites of
these girls going oh my god
the sloth girls in the church no she is
not oh my god
things are getting crazy and I said no
they're not someone's just in a costume
in a tree that's not crazy so it was
still part of the bit still part of the
[ __ ] so she stayed in the costume
intros in like while the girls were
funneling into the house and then she
like stayed up in the tree then
eventually goes we would come down from
there and then she like takes off the
mask and it's like how she was getting
his attention to like be memorable which
is you know good strategy it worked but
you know what I'm saying crazy boring
people yeah that's a weird boring thing
that's what we're boring crazy thing to
do yeah and then to your point I'm
saying everyone in that house going like
oh my guys is crazy I'm like your
[ __ ] life sucks if you think someone
in a costume in a tree it's crazy that's
not quite you know crazy is like someone
like doing 10 line like 10 rails of coke
out of somebody's ass and then walking
in the next room and then like kissing
his girlfriend that's crazy yeah you
know be crazy if some girl just pulled
up in those intros and just dropped his
pants and started sucking his dick that
would be crazy
that would be crazy whoa just sexually
assaulted a final rose please the final
rose they will add the golden buzzer
like America's Got Talent
just as advances are right to the final
rites here oh Jessica we've had a
fantastic 30 seconds together
I just want to know will you spend the
rest of your a very virgin thing to do
so bro dude there was so much that
happened I'm like this show is to me I
this is not rooted in anything but I
felt like the producers to that show
were like oh [ __ ] love violence coming
to America we got to try to turn up as
hard as we can because we're gonna lose
viewers oh yeah so they changed the
format of the show where this because
the opening the first episode is always
like two and a half hours it's always
stupid
that's another that's what I mean like I
tat like I do pit they take the
shittiest stuff and stretch it out and
just milking yeah yeah not funny people
oh yeah and then I can add revenue they
never have any like real drama like they
always take drama it dude it's one big
it's like a b-level YouTube vlog like
they bait you with some [ __ ] and
literally what's in the title never
happens yeah you know like on the last
season they tried to make it seem like
these two guys got in a fight and some
dude left like on a stretcher some dude
rolled over in his sleep in it and
because they have him sleeping the
shitty like you know single
concentration camp beds I fell through a
glass table because they didn't think
booking a bunch of six-foot dudes and
putting him in tiny little beds would
[ __ ] pan out poorly when you try to
make him sleep in a racecar bed like he
just rolled over in his sleep and then
just [ __ ] went I got a bunch of glass
in his face I was like oh my god what
defects going on yeah that's kind of
dope that is kind of dope Gore that's
what they should have put in the trailer
like they should have intentionally did
that yeah I'm saying thing is that the
only thing I actually interesting that
happens they it was an accident right
right they should've put glass
everywhere so so whatever this for this
show or for this episode like this
season
god I can't talk they had all these
people this is the goofiest [ __ ] instead
of heard of my life they had all these
people come with a Fonda theater they
try to make it into like a party so the
people like standing around and they're
shooting it with like the guy Chris you
know like oh what's up bachelor nation
it is poppin off in here it's getting
dumb lydian here bachelor nation he hit
one of those like he hit like a super
dated phrase like that I was like oh my
oh yeah goddamn it hashtag every day we
list yeah yeah it was something where he
dropped it and aleena like was eating
she goes did that [ __ ] really
just say that and so you know whatever
it is going absolutely sick mo to your
destination
talk about mo Bamba
so dude it's like it's a standing party
and he goes we're doing things a little
bit different for this bachelor season
kickoff cuz it's gonna be the most
dramatic season you've ever seen they
say this literally the past three I've
watched every time so there's a big
screen behind him and he goes we're
doing things a little bit different here
we want to cut over to Lansing Michigan
and they cut to a broadcast of a house
party with two like former Bachelorette
contestants it's like two guys and a
bunch of just pent-up married women like
horny as extras just like standing in
this house and there's like a couple
hosting this bachelor season kickoff
it's just awkward house party of like 30
people and then these two dudes that are
like dude this guy get river this he
goes what's up Chris oh my god first of
all it's only 30 people you know what 30
people looks like yeah in a room it's
not that many
you also can't even make that look like
it's a lot of people no it's not it's
not a and especially in a house there's
not enough depth like it just looks like
a wall of people ends up looking like a
dodgeball line it's not that cool so you
guys Grover yeah so he goes oh my god
Chris look at this look at this it's
pandemonium fandemonium yeah you said
that about to turn the TV off and like
get this [ __ ] out of here and then it's
a 35 year old [ __ ] you conservative
mothers their sweater the [ __ ] out
turtlenecks tight you know I'm saying
extra baggy around the breast even if
they got some they're not showing
they're just like the screams feel just
so kind of safe everything about it is
safe so then here's like medium
turtleneck with an extra small neck yeah
so then he says some more goofy [ __ ] and
Chris goes wait wait I got to stop you
cuz I gotta cut over to my other friends
out in look in Austin Texas and she's a
bunch of people standing out in the cold
with bachelor signs it's like it doesn't
even look I don't know where the
they all look like a parking lot I have
no idea what like why they're just
standing around dude wait for it yeah
what does he say what did he say it's
like some girl who was a virgin on like
a previous season check married some guy
and whatever and she goes I'm standing
here with blah blah blah and he has
something he has to get off his chest
this guy's like you know huh you know
I'm really happy to be around here
around all this love and energy and uh
Catherine um I just want to say that I
am so happy that I found you in my life
and and you know our relationships a lot
like The Bachelor and that we started
very fast and when you went away that
summer I I knew that you were the one
for me so so I came to you and I stayed
with you and four years later here we
are and Catherine gets I don't with me
any [ __ ] proposes to her right there
and it's the most Awkward [ __ ] because
it's again it's only like 30 people and
they're all just standing there like oh
I didn't I just I thought we were gonna
watch the show I didn't what do we do
and then this turtleneck is so - yeah
yeah and then the girls like and he was
talking way too long like that
awkwardness you felt right there
multiply that by four I could feel like
the producers being like this well we're
gonna wrap it up
[Music]
not trying to flex take your vision
notion right that's not a flex